Harvey Weinstein fire from his own
company et has the statement released by
The Weinstein Company Board of
Representatives on Sunday it reads in
part quote in light of new information
about misconduct by Harvey Weinstein
that has emerged in the past few days
the directors of The Weinstein Company
have determined and have informed Harvey
Weinstein that his employment with the
Weinstein Company is terminated
effective immediately Weinstein's firing
comes on the heels of an explosive
report published in The New York Times
on Thursday the studio head was accused
of three decades of sexual harassment by
actress Ashley Judd and more women in
Hollywood in a statement to ET on
Thursday Weinstein's lawyer Charles J
harder called the New York Times report
saturated with false and defamatory
statements harder also added that
Weinstein is planning to file a lawsuit
all proceeds will be donated to women's
organizations a New York Times
spokesperson said the publication stands
by its reporting the article also claims
that the film mogul has reached eight
settlements with women over sexual
harassment claims from 1990 to 2015
additionally Weinstein issued a lengthy
apology on Thursday he said he's working
with therapists and taking a leave of
absence from his company to deal with
his issues he said in part quote I
appreciate the way I've behaved with
colleagues in the past has caused a lot
of pain and I sincerely apologize for it
though I'm trying to do better I know I
have a long way to go a former employee
at The Weinstein Company who wished to
remain anonymous tells et the
accusations against Weinstein are
nothing new adding they don't think
anything will change